you know that Megan and Harry when they
were at the funeral for the queen felt
like they hadn't been received well they
weren't getting the respect that they
were owed or dude yet at the same time
there is this Memoir that is looming
right of Harry's that's coming out early
next year there were podcasts there was
the Oprah bombshell interview one could
see why they weren't warmly received at
the Queen's funeral right oh sure just
how many Bombshells does the Royal
Family need to worry about that could be
included in this Memoir of Harris God
knows I mean this is going to be another
you know series of grenades they're
tossing into the palace I mean uh
they're just uh terrified of the royal
family uh Charles and Camilla and the
rest of them about what Harry could say
particularly since I understand so much
of it has to do with his upbringing the
marriage of Charles and Diana and you
know it's all of you through his lens
but don't forget you know Harry was
always the the rebel Prince you know he
had a drug problem as a teenager uh he
wore a Nazi uniform to a costume party
uh he made remarks that were interpreted
as uh anti-muslim in all of these cases
his father really came to his rescue but
now I think they've gone a step too far
in terms of what Charles is willing to
put up with we'll have to wait and see
if they can bridge the gap the trouble
is Charles has got to
take this monarchy in the direction he
wants it to go and for that to happen I
think he's always felt he needs all
hands on deck and that would include
Megan and uh and Harry and I think
Charles feels betrayed because in the
beginning the royal family really
embraced Megan if you remember those
wonderful pictures of the queen on her
first trip with Megan and they're on the
Royal Train they're going Northwest
England They're laughing they really hit
it off and there's a lot of warmth there
that I think surprised a lot of people
is instant rapport it was Charles who
walked Megan down the second half of the
aisle when her father wouldn't show up
it was Charles would befriended Doria
Ragland Megan's mother they really
seemed to have a really seem to have
clicked and so now to have her say the
things she's saying and sort of turn on
them in this sense I think it's very
hurtful but also according to reporting
in your book it's been said by many
sources that Charles was the one who was
speculating what their first child would
look like that's true that kind of skin
color that's true that's true but I
think that was you know again in their
defense it was a casual remark made at
the very beginning of the relationship
and uh of two people just looking at
what their grandchildren might look like
and so and it was twistingly twisted and
contorted absolutely it was by the again
the these kind of shadowy figures that
exist in within the structure of the
monarchy in the various competing
palaces